autre manifestation organisée cet après
midi cette fois ci à l'appel de florian
philippot le chef de file du mouvement
des patriotes
manifestation suivie par david kelly
phare
david bonjour vous êtes vous du côté de
l'école militaire la mobilisation était
là au rendez-vous david
[Applaudissements]
la vie se fit plusieurs milliers de
personnes une nouvelle fois réunis
devant l'école militaire le cortège doit
partir pour se rendre vers place qu'on
croit dans le 7e arrondissement de paris
est allée samedi se ressemblent pour
c'est un manifestant qui ne compte pas
baisser les bras montrer que la
mobilisation est toujours présente et
qu' il n'y a pas d'essoufflement du
mouvement contrairement à ce que disent
elles et l autorité pas là l'objectif
principal pour ces manifestants qui
réclament également évidemment le
retrait pur et simple un dieu un projet
de loi concernant l'extension du pass
tanit est rentrée en vigueur depuis le 9
août dernier et qui oblige les français
a montré patte blanche dans certains
lieux de la vie quotidienne alors on se
souvient que le gouvernement avait
maintes et maintes fois promis à queue
il ne serait pas nécessaire aux français
c'est aussi pour cette raison que les
manifestants sont dans la rue cet après
midi à montrer les contradictions
successives à de l'exécutif durant cette
crise sanitaire elle vous propose d'en
écouter quelques uns et puis la france
c'est quelque chose où je n'arrive pas à
imaginer que ça puisse nous arriver en
un an et demi quand on ait pu en arriver
là donc c'est insupportable pour moi la
liberté est un droit fondamental que
personne ne peut enlever même pas un
président de la république
ensuite je pense que si les gens ne
veulent pas d'un modèle chinois bah ils
feraient bien si de se réveiller parce
que on y va tout droit pourquoi obliger
tout le monde il ya des gens qui n'ont
pas besoin qu'ils sont en bonne santé
qui prennent pas de médicaments sont pas
malades pourquoi les obliger
je pense que là mais il s'en va durer
jusqu'à jusqu'à temps que ces mesures
dureront pas ce que les gens en ont
assez on a assez du masque en a assez du
pass sanitaires on aime bien c'est
revivre normalement et librement comme
avant moi j'aime pas du passé sanitaires
et on se battra jusqu'au bout pour le
faire retirer c'est hors de question
qu'on sépare les gens sur leur état
sérologique donc je continue à être là
tant que le pass sanitaire sera là
en tout cas le chef de file des
patriotes florian philippot à
l'initiative de ces rassemblements ne
compte pas baisser les bras et
poursuivre le combat pour dénoncer la
fota qui considèrent comme liberticide
tous les samedis il sera dans la rue
afin de montrer au gouvernement que ce
texte ne convient pas aux libertés
individuelles ne convient pas à la
france le pour lui le mot résignation ne
fait pas partie du vocabulaire français
y goûter
[Musique]
la résignation n'est pas dans l'esprit
français voilà quand l'esprit de foule
en français se lève qu'il se réveille il
va jusqu'au et on obtiendra la fin de
cette loi de la honte la fin du pass de
la honte aux antilles les soignants ont
gagné veron a dû dire non mais y aura
pas pour l'instant de vaccination
coville au byetta pour les soignants
parce qu'ils se sont mobilisés qu'ils
ont résisté alors c'est au peuple
français partout métropole outre-mer de
le faire
rassemblements encadrés par un important
dispositif de sécurité - consultant que
les samedis un précédent mais qui est
bien présent à moins qu'il n'ait aucun
un débordement le portege fils on courra
jusqu'à au terme de cette manifestation
place au bois ou des prises de balle on
rend public succéderont et pour le
moment l'ambiance est plutôt festive et
musicale à club vous pouvez entendre
merci beaucoup david qualify on
retrouvera nos reporters tout au long de
cet après midi pour suivre cette
mobilisation